las autoridades de florida informaron de
daños en infraestructura y cortes del
suministro eléctrico que iniciaron antes
del impacto con más de 570 mil hogares
afectados para los ciudadanos las
fuertes inundaciones fueron sorpresivas
martí no estábamos demasiado preocupados
porque seguían diciendo que iba a ser
una categoría 1 y cuando llegó fue una 2
había mucho viento mucha lluvia
en alabama cerca de 300.000 se quedaron
sin electricidad y en misisipí los
puntos afectados se acercaron a 10.000
sin embargo los daños no fueron tantos
como se esperaba
si van a pasar ya sabes dos o tres
semanas antes de que todo vuelva a la
normalidad pero no hay ningún daño
importante salida es el primer huracán
que toca tierra en alabama desde 2004 y
las inundaciones que trajo consigo
fueron calificadas de repentinas y
catastróficas todavía se teme por
posibles desbordamientos de ríos e
incluso tornados en algunas partes del
noroeste de florida el sur de alabama y
el suroeste de georgia en el golfo de
méxico tras tocar tierra con vientos de
casi 165 kilómetros por hora la tormenta
presenta ahora vientos máximos
sostenidos de 110 kilómetros por hora
mientras continúa su trayectoria hacia
el sureste de alabama y el extremo
noroccidental de florida para este
jueves se terminará como depresión en la
costa de las carolinas salí fue el
octavo huracán de esta temporada en el
atlántico y actualmente hay otras tres
tormentas activas lo que
de 2020 uno de los años con más
fenómenos registrados